- Hi, everybody, it's Gary Vaynerchuk.
Another episode of podSessions.
Awesome scene I just walked into,
there's like 30 people in my office.
It was buzzing, exactly how I love it,
I sat down and shit got quiet.
So I'm freaking out, I'm excited to get
the noise a little bit louder.
Three phenomenal guests again.
I will let them introduce
themselves in a second.
And actually, I'm just
gonna go right into it.
I was gonna make a comment about
my shitty fantasy baseball team,
but nobody needs to hear my troubles
and so let's move on,
let's go ladies first.
Why don't we give the
audience that's listening
a little bit of an origin story?
So who you are, what you're about.
Actually, let's start with who you are
and what you're up to,
and then I'll take it from there.
- Awesome, yeah,
Anastasia, and I've been
surfing my whole life.
I've been a professional surfer
for the last 20-something years.
I traveled around the world.
I don't compete actively anymore.
- [Gary] What years did you compete?
How old from how old?
- Five years old to, you
know, up until last year.
I'm 31, so yeah, it's been a great ride
and throughout this whole time,
I've always been producing my own videos,
doing photos for sponsors and brands,
even when I was a young kid.
And really started popping
off with me was social media
and being able to have my own platform,
and so now I get to do what
I've always loved doing,
is surf videos, fun photos, traveling,
and, really, social
media's been great for me.
- And where do you live now?
- I live actually in Florida now.
- [Gary] Okay, and you grew up where?
- I'm from Hawaii and California.
- [Gary] You're in surf land.
- Yeah, I've definitely been everywhere
tropical, warm, beach towns.
- Did you want to get
out of the West Coast
or was Florida for business
reasons or any other reasons?
- Personal, my boyfriend brought me there,
but I'm always on the road.
It's a nice home base to come home to.
- [Gary] Awesome.
My guy.
- Rob Pannell, played
professional lacrosse,
going into my sixth year.
From New York, grew up here originally.
I played for New York
Lizards and Team USA.
So heading into the World
Games are the big thing
I'm looking forward to this summer.
- [Gary] That's every four years, right?
- Every four years, yeah.
- [Gary] Excited?
- Can't wait, yeah.
- [Gary] You've done that once before
or is this your first time?
- 2014, we lost to Canada.
- [Gary] You're pissed.
- Yeah, I'm pissed.
A little bit of chip on our shoulder,
but yeah, in Israel in July.
- And how are you feeling about this run?
- Feeling good, feeling confident.
- [Gary] Do we feel confident?
- New team, new coach.
- [Gary] Is Canada gonna be great again?
- They'll be great, yeah.
They're always talented.
- [Gary] And who's emerged
in the last 40 years,
in your opinion, on the world stage?
Anybody else you got your eye on of,
like, "That's gonna be real competition."
- I think Team Israel, they're hosting,
but I think they can maybe challenge
the Iroquois for that Bronze medal.
Australia is always there but Israel,
in the past, hasn't been that great.
- But, for most experts,
it's gonna be us, you guys, and Canada.
- Yeah, I think only one other time
it hasn't been US or Canada in the finals.
- [Gary] So you're focused.
- Just focused on Canada.
- And what kind of brings you here?
Obviously Tyler is a huge lacrosse fan,
or Paul or like, you've hacked your way,
but from a business standpoint
and things of that nature,
where's your mindset at?
- I think the unique thing
about the lacrosse world
is that we're professional athletes,
but we're not paid like other sports,
so we gotta find other
ways to make a living
and I think the social
landscape has allowed us to,
you know guys like myself, guys like Paul,
to do it full-time so it's challenging,
but you gotta find ways to get creative
and most guys in the professional league
are going into another job.
I'm lucky that I'm building a brand
that I'm able to do it full-time.
So getting creative
whether it's developing
my own platform for instruction online,
for kids to watch videos;
doing workout videos on social media
that kids wanna follow along;
just kind of building my brand over years.
And kind of feel myself, right now,
more focused on it, more than ever.
- Good for you, man.
Aubs?
- Yeah, what's up, everybody?
Aubrey Marcus.
I'm the founder and CEO
of a company called Onnit,
which is one of the leaders
in human performance.
We call it Total Human Optimization.
And I put all that knowledge from working
with the best people in the world,
a lifetime of experience
and clinical research,
and put that into a new book called
'Own the Day, Own Your Life',
which is compressing
all of these practices
for Total Human Optimization
into one single day.
- It's a big, fat book, bro.
- [Aubrey] Big, fat book.
It's heavy.
- Yeah, man.
I feel like you yapped a
little bit too much in this.
This is real, this is a lot.
- There's a lot to the game my friend,
a lot to the game.
- [Gary] Respect.
- Every chapter covers a
different section of the day,
from waking up to having
sex to going to sleep
to what you should eat
breakfast, lunch, dinner,
the whole thing.
So having a glass of wine.
Tries to cover like a real life day,
rather than just a
health book that's gonna
have everybody--
- And when does this hit, tomorrow?
- April 17th.
- 17th, so a week from this recording,
and are you nervous, are you excited?
- Man, I paid the blood
price for this book,
so I'm not nervous, you know?
I did everything I could so at that point,
when you do your best, you
lay it all on the line,
you can't be tied to the
expectations of what it does.
There was not a single point where I had
a chance to rewrite or a
chance to put my best effort in
and I didn't do it so
I laid it on the line,
so whatever happens, happens.
- Congrats, brother.
They're like children but
they definitely are special.
I'm excited it's here,
I'm excited for people
to get to know you more in this session.
So let's go back around the room,
and this is my favorite
part of the podSessions.
I wanna know what you're
currently obsessed with.
And when I say that, I
prefer that it not be,
like, what your life is
about or what you care about.
I don't want Aubrey's answer to be,
"I'm obsessed with maximizing--"
I want it to something ridiculously small,
like this new T-shirt that you just got
that somebody gave you
that's so fucking soft
you don't know how you
ever lived without it
or like a new Netflix show or, like,
some new food or restaurant
that opened by you.
I think it's really interesting
the way we live our lives,
like how some little thing
becomes a new current obsession.
So let's go back around, what
is your current obsession?
- I have a couple.
My current obsession right now,
and I don't know where or
why I got so into this,
is basically whenever I'm traveling
I just love watching, on Instagram,
stories from cities, different cities.
Even if I'm not even traveling, I'm home,
I'll be like, "Oh, I
wanna know what's going on
"at this hot spot around the world,"
and I like watching real-time,
real people on the internet.
Not necessarily like
influencers or celebrities.
Real real-time people.
- And will it be as
macro as, like, Coachella
or will it be something
like, "I'm just curious
"what the fuck's happening in
De Moines, Iowa, right now."
Somewhere in between?
- Like Paris or like London.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, it doesn't need to be
like a cultural event like Coachella,
like, snooze.
I have seen enough
hipster outfits, you know?
- Seen enough flowers and hair?
- [Anastasia] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- For a lifetime.
- Yeah, I've been to Coachella ten times.
I'm Coachella-ed out,
but yeah, no, just like random
cities and other things,
and then my also other obsession recently,
which actually happened yesterday,
I was telling my friends that I just
swooped some new re-done or
brought back LA Gear stuff.
- LA Gear.
- Yeah, and I was like,
"This is so tight."
- I love that.
So what did you get, sneakers or--?
- I know I got some just crop top shorts.
- You can still get those LA Gear Lites.
- [Anastasia] Yeah, I
wanna get those next.
- eBay.
I want the original stuff, not the remade.
Love that, LA Gear.
Perfect, perfect answer.
My man?
- Short-term, I'd say this
weekend was the Masters.
That's my favorite sport.
- You were just, like, enthralled.
- Dialed in the whole weekend.
- Dialed in Thursday or
dialed in Saturday, Sunday?
- Thursday, Friday, Saturday, Sunday.
- Like you just were not productive?
Like Tyler wasn't super productive?
- I don't wanna throw
myself under the bus,
but yeah, I was live stream on my phone.
- Did you bet, did you bet on someone?
- I didn't bet on the Masters.
- So do you have a core guy or two
or a great gal golf friend?
- Yeah, so my buddy and
I played on Saturday,
played 18 holes then watched
before training camp started,
and then Sunday.
- So you guys were just texting each other
and be like, "Holy shit, look,
Jordan just did this hole."
- Actually, a few guys I have like that.
- So the Masters, that's super awesome.
That's been really
interesting for me to watch.
No matter how when the
true 30 for 30 or movie doc
comes out about the Tiger
Effect on pop culture,
but literally just being 42,
being in that zone where
Tiger kind of came up,
but also being in the
wine business as a kid
and mainly hanging out with
high-net-worth individuals
that were in their 40s to 80s,
just watching, in one generation,
the interest in golf
become so much younger.
And now you've got this whole
new kind of group of guys
and it's kind of just drink
Natty Lite and use social
and do ridiculous guys
things has created a wave,
but it's really interesting
how cultural the Masters
has become for people 20
to 40 instead of 40 to 80,
as it was when I was growing up as a kid.
- [Rob] Absolutely.
- And, like, did you like golf as a kid?
- Yeah, my dad had a club in
my hand when I was 3 years old,
so I love it.
- There's a lot of young
sports going on around here.
Club in hand at 3, on a
surfboard professionally at 5,
it's pretty gnarly.
Aub?
- Yeah, I would say one
thing that's been interesting
is I did a lot of research
on tobacco for the book,
as a performance enhancer,
and I started getting into Swedish Snus,
which is one of the cleanest
forms of a chewing tobacco.
- Okay.
So you're gonna get mouth cancer.
Just asking.
- Well, it depends on obviously frequency.
There's some risk, there's
some risk involved,
but Royal London College of Physicians
says it's like 10 to 1000 times safer
than smoking cigarettes
or something like that,
and nicotine itself
isn't really the issue,
a lot of the associated
things with tobacco,
and the Swedish Snus is one
of the cleaner versions.
I'm not saying there's no risk.
- How often are you dipping?
Is it dipping?
- Yeah, well you put a
little pouch in your mouth.
- So how often are you dipping?
- I'm saying, like,
maybe four times a week,
but it's probably my favorite drug.
- Because you feel
amazing as it's happening?
- You feel amazing as
it's happening, right?
People know me and follow me,
I've experienced a lot
of the psychedelic drugs,
a lot of the things.
If I had to probably say,
"Alright, no more drugs.
"No more caffeine, no more
alcohol, no more anything."
- Is sugar in there?
- No sugar.
Oh, is sugar a drug?
- So I'm the reverse.
I've never ever done anything drug,
I've never tried any
tobacco product in my life
outside of literally alcohol.
- I could fucking blow
your mind right now, Gary.
I got a Swedish Snus right in my bag.
- You know what's funny?
I need to go the other way, bro.
Like, I have so much
natural adrenaline and high,
it's so amazing to me how I
never gravitated towards that.
I think my mom was also
super, super brainwashed
by Nancy Reagan and "No
More Drugs" or "Say No"
or whatever the fuck that was in the '80s.
But actually, the true answer is,
and you'll find this interesting,
for everybody listening,
my mom grew up in Soviet Russia where,
one, the Soviet Union was so miserable
that most people died at 60.
Two, the amount of vodka consumed
in that country is just so overwhelming.
So my mom basically saw
every male figure she knew
ever, outside of like one grandpa,
like drink themselves
into oblivions as a norm.
Like, it's really funny,
when I got to college,
in high school there
was a drinking culture,
but college,
I'll just never forget my
wedding rehearsal night,
my uncles dismantled my friends.
It was just the best scene I'd ever seen.
All my buddies, who
thought they could drink,
my uncles drank a liter
of Gray Goose to the face
every single normal holiday.
Like, literally a half a bottle of vodka
was the equivalent to normal Americans
having a glass of
champagne as an aperitif.
So I think my mom was super affected
and kind of pushed me
in the other direction,
but it's really, really,
really interesting to me
because I do think, on the flip side,
I'm always fascinated by
what the establishment
has made a negative versus a positive.
The way I think about school,
the way I think about a lot of things,
I actually subconsciously
understand that truth
around most drugs and
things of that nature.
So for example, I'm
unbelievably undereducated
when I make this statement
because I don't need to get
destroyed in the comments section
and have to spend an hour contexting it.
I say this with full transparency,
I'm super undereducated on
everything about that world,
but I am fascinated
intuitively around steroids,
for example.
Like, it always runs through my mind that,
like, "Hmm, what's the
real punchline there?"
- If, next time we hope,
you're dunking a basketball,
then we'll know.
- We'll know exactly what happened.
So that, that has become huge for me.
And what's the subculture around--
What's it called one more time?
- Snus, S-N-U-S.
It's biohacker, it's people trying to find
the cleanest way to deliver the nicotine,
which it's a really interesting
feeling when you push
the boundary because it
starts off kind of excitable,
like you get a little
energy like a stimulant,
and then everything gets
really heavy and quiet.
Almost like you're spearfishing
at the bottom of the water,
when everything gets really still.
I mean, you've probably done that before.
It's like this crazy feeling
that'll settle over your body
and that's the part
that's really enjoyable
because for me I'm a little bit like you,
my mind's always running
and this actually takes you
beyond that point and kinda drops you in.
- Let me ask a question
to all three of you.
How much do you like being in control?
- A lot.
- How do you think about drinking, drugs?
As you were talking, the
thought of going mundane
or like being in the bottom, spearfishing,
one of the things that's
been interesting to me
is I've not been drunk a lot in my life
and I grew up in the alcohol business,
I grew up in America.
Like, I think about the reason why,
no question for me the reason
I don't like asking for things,
a lot of my content lately
has been about this,
I've realized, and it just
summed up as you were talking.
My greatest angst, the
thing I hate the most,
is not being in control.
The reason I love running
my own ship is I do not
wanna be at the mercy
of anything but myself,
and one of the reasons I've not liked
being drunk or getting into any zone is
I don't like not being in control.
I could see one arguing that is control,
I'm fascinated by that,
but you said you love being in control.
- Yeah, I mean, for me I
love having a couple drinks,
but in moderation.
Like, social, have a drink to--
- Do you agree with me that if you're off,
you know, your rocker and/or mellowed out,
do you feel less in control?
- Yeah, 100 percent.
- But when you're surfing, though,
I mean, in that state,
it is a state of being out of control.
It's a state of surrender
naturally, right?
Like, you get out of your head completely.
- I feel like you were in control.
- You are in control but you are
dealing with an uncontrollable element.
- [Gary] Understood.
- Yeah, so you can't--
- But that's life.
Like, I'm in control but Seth might
punch me in the fucking face right now.
(laughing)
Like, I need to be prepared at all times.
A dude with a pink hat
may stab me in my neck.
I'm always aware of what's happening.
You know?
- I'm the same way.
I think everything affects
people differently.
So, you know, you talk about
experimenting with different things,
I have and you feel out of control
and you're like, "I don't
wanna do that again,"
is probably the reason why I don't
do certain things as much
as other people do it.
I don't drink a ton.
If I'm drinking, I'm
going out and drinking.
- You're binary.
You're not gonna be casual.
- I might have a few casual, you know,
but that's like, you know,
very rare these days.
Yeah, I mean, if you
actually play lacrosse--
No, it's not that bad.
People will tell you that,
they think I'm always in control.
Like, they've never seen
me crazy out of control
when I go out but I'm not--
You know, I was a captain in college,
always overlooking the
team when we were out,
you know, at the fraternity.
I always had to make sure
everything was gonna be okay.
If you watch me play lacrosse,
I kinda operate at like 80% speed.
I'm never, you know, full go for it.
- Because of injury, even?
Overplaying?
- I don't wanna get myself into a position
that I can't get out of
so I wanna be in control.
- Aub, when you go there
with experimenting things,
are you conscious before you go there
to put yourself in a position
where you're controlled?
- You know, 100%.
So, like, I think being unconsciously
out of control is a horrible idea,
whether you're partying
or whether whatever.
If you're unconsciously out
of control that's terrible,
but there is so much fucking magic
in super conscious surrender.
So, like, if you're doing a psychedelic
or if you're just completely
allowing something to happen,
there's real magic on
the bleeding into that.
- Do you feel that magic of that
plays out back in the
quote, unquote, real world
because you have the context of the two?
- Yeah, absolutely, and then when that
uncontrollable element happens,
you've practiced and
you've trained the art
of completing letting go and not
resisting the irresistible
force, you know?
And so it helps you get
over these emotional issues
that you would normally obsess over.
It helps you move beyond
and see the assistance
that's coming on the
backside of the resistance.
- What's happening in that subculture?
Like, obviously, you know, our
friend Tim Farris and others,
like, it would be obvious
to me just living in culture
that there is huge momentum in the
kind of like that 20 to
30-year-old alpha male
acceptance of psychedelics
and experimental
that is far more accepted
right now, in my opinion.
What are you seeing in the subculture?
It feels like it's two, three
years, four years into this.
What are we seeing?
- A lot of high performers,
myself included,
are deeply unhappy on certain levels
with ourself in some particular way.
We're super driven and we catalyze a lot
of that energy from early trauma
and early expectations
we couldn't live up to,
and we catalyze that into outward exertion
of effort as an entrepreneur.
- How old are you?
- I'm 37.
- 28.
- But the deep unhappiness that we feel,
these are tools to allow us to get down
to the roots of that and
start pulling the weeds
and healing the cracks in the foundation,
and I think that's what's
driving people too.
- You feel like when you're in that state,
you're able to have that
conversation with yourself?
- Fuck yeah.
Like, see little things
that were blind to me,
patterns that developed from my parents,
things that I've been driven by,
pleasing a certain person or living up
to this expectation and unravels that.
- Have you gone that route as well?
- Yeah, totally.
- And has that been a positive as well?
- The thing is you can't talk about
what you can't see, you know?
So you can talk like, "Oh, yeah,
"I think things are pretty good,"
but you're blind, you're
blind until you become
aware of what it is and
then you can start talking
and then allow people, experts,
psychiatrists, other people
to help you clean up
what you became aware of.
- Let me use this as a building block
to change the conversation,
but actually build right on top of that.
Us three performers, this
is super interesting to me,
what you just said.
I am fascinated by the
last 20 years of parenting,
so I think it is,
in America and I've seen parts of Asia,
I just don't have enough context outside,
but in America over the last 20 years,
I feel like the parenting has--
And this is obviously a
very blanket statement,
enough that I'm starting the foundations
of the book I've been
yelling about for years
called Perfectly Parented,
I'm super fascinated by not the coddling,
but it's really one thing.
When there's abundance
parents will always do this.
During good times, you
even look at parents,
parenting during the Roaring Twenties,
when things are good you start
worrying about dumb shit.
When you have nothing you
worry about food and shelter,
you do not worry about how
long you waited for Uber
and, "Fuck, why do it go
around the block again?"
It's just life.
My parents, when they
first came to America
when we lived in the studio
apartment the size of this,
they're worried about certain shit,
it's just normal.
So after three generations
of abundance in America,
and obviously this is a net America,
there's obviously Mississippi has not been
crushing it for the
last three generations,
or most of it unfortunately,
which is a whole other
obsession of mine, Mississippi,
but I haven't really talked about it yet.
I'm very fascinated by parents
trying to protect kids from using,
like in a big way.
Like, especially now that I'm a parent,
just watching parents
talk about things like,
"We have to invite everybody
to the birthday party,"
you know, just like stuff
that is so ridiculous to me.
As three competitors,
and it sounds like you
started athletics super early and all,
but I'm projecting but I
think you did as well, right?
Do you feel like that was
a great thing for you?
Did your parents try to actually
manipulate some not losing,
did you see it?
What is your three opinions
on this notion very simply,
that losing a lot young is actually
the great advantage to life,
not a disadvantage,
that I think parents have unbelievably,
tried to protect kids from losing,
we've changed so much of
our athletics in the US.
We don't have keeping score until,
like, fucking fifth grade.
It's real intense.
It's a very interesting conversation
and, to me, you start talking
about unwinding things,
look, kids have to unwind
alcoholism and abuse
and a lot of hardcore stuff that you can't
predict or things of that nature.
Watching the country,
and I'm talking about
the liberal and the conservative,
I love when I bring this up,
a lot of the homies from Alabama are like,
"Yeah, you fucking New York and LA homies.
"Gary, go them."
I'm weird.
When somebody hits me
up on Twitter and says,
"Yeah, you're so right.
"The New York, LA liberal shit.
"Get them, Gary, I love you,"
I look at their account and I'm like,
"Okay, this town in Arkansas,"
I like Google and look up the
rules of their soccer league
and then like reply to them,
be like, "Yo, dude, your league has
"fucking 8th place trophies, too."
So this is, like, a net thing.
What is your two cents, three cents
on this whole conversation?
- Yeah, I mean, I 1000% agree.
I mean, like the way I was brought up
it was like either you're
a winner or you're a loser,
and it worked.
I mean, for me, too, I
remember I used to cry.
I was so emotional about
getting second place
because it was either you win or you lose.
- And how did your parents
deal with the crying?
- They were like, "Well, you didn't win."
- [Gary] Right, "Cry."
- Yeah, they were like, "Yeah,"
you know, "do better next time."
- I cried basically minimally once a week
for the first 13 years of my life.
This is not a joke.
I would cry all the time.
I just cried every time I lost.
Until I was 9, I cried every time I lost.
Like, dead tears, like death tears.
To the point where nobody
really wanted to play with me.
(laughing)
I'm being serious.
And I could tell when
people were letting me win,
and that would make me cry, too.
So I was just crying.
- Yeah, no, and for me, too.
I thought it was very interesting
when I was a young kid because I was,
like, obsessed with getting
first in every event
and when I would go over
to my friend's houses
that had participation trophies
and trophies in their room,
and I was always like, "What?
"What place did you get?"
- Did they think you
were too much, seriously?
- [Anastasia] Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- Did you have to learn how
to coddle that a little bit?
Because I definitely did.
- When I was 12, 13, I was
doing shoots for Teen Magazine
and I was like coming up and
getting attention and stuff,
and that was also weird, too.
I wasn't bullied but people
were definitely like--
- "You think you're special."
- Well, and also, too,
when I was growing up,
surfing wasn't cool for girls,
so that's a whole other thing,
but it was like, "Oh, you're like a dude.
"You're like a tomboy, you're not cute."
You know?
It was a lot of that stuff but yeah.
- Did you care or were you so deep into
surfing that you didn't give a fuck?
Or did you cry?
- No, that never made me cry.
Losing made me cry.
- [Gary] Love it, what about for you?
- I think it starts with parenting.
I mean, I almost didn't
play college lacrosse
because I wasn't recruited,
I felt like I didn't have
many options to go to school.
At one point, I had no options.
My fifth year of high school,
trying to go somewhere,
but I think it was because of how my--
- [Gary] How'd you end up in
a fifth year in high school?
- I wasn't recruited so I took a
post-graduate at a prep school.
- So you were that hardcore?
And that's where I
thought you were gonna go.
So you were that religious of, like,
"Fuck this, I'm playing lacrosse."
- Yeah, at least that's where my dad,
when I was younger it was all about being,
you know, the best you could be
and being the best and winning,
and I was good when I was younger.
- That's such an intense gear.
Like, I can't even think of anybody I know
that took a fucking fifth
year of high school.
To me, why didn't you accept that
the market said you weren't good enough?
Because it was still one more option
and you needed to,
like, scratch that itch?
I mean this when I say this,
I'd love for anybody to shoot their hat,
I don't even know anybody
who ever took a fifth year
of high school to get into a sport.
Like, that's an intense jump.
- Yeah, I love lacrosse, I
had that dream of playing
Division One lacrosse at
the highest level possible,
playing on Memorial Day in
the National Championship,
and when that wasn't happening I was like,
"Okay, what do I need to do
differently to be better?"
And I kept working, working,
put so much time and effort into it.
- When did it set in
that wasn't happening?
Late junior year?
- I was recruited at, like,
Division Three, Division Two.
- But we're not talking
Hopkins and Syracuse.
- I'd say my junior to senior year,
I was committed to a Division One school,
I was outside the top
fifty and I was like,
"Okay, this is my last
push to make this happen."
- Like junior year going to senior year,
you had a hedge and you were like,
"But I'm gonna fucking dismantle it
"and somebody's gonna
see that and swoop in."
- Yeah, and then I did that.
I just said, "I'm not coming,"
and I took a fifth year
at the prep school.
- So you did that senior year,
and that didn't happen, right?
Your top ten school didn't come in.
- I actually made this
decision after my senior year.
I made it in the summer after senior year,
I said, "I'm not coming."
- To this school.
- [Rob] Yeah.
- And you said, "I'm gonna
go to this prep school."
And that's allowed?
- Yeah.
Not really.
I signed a contract, I
was supposed to be there,
so technically I could only
look at non-scholarship schools.
- Oh, that part.
I mean like prep school.
So what ended up happening?
You go to the prep
school and what happens?
- I was talking to a few schools,
they all told me they
didn't have room for me,
couldn't get me in,
and at one point in October,
the reason I was there,
play regional lacrosse,
I was dunking anyone.
And then out of nowhere Cornell came and--
- You have to be registered
every year or how did it--
- I'll be there next year.
It was crazy, I remember
calling around crying
when these two other schools
told me they couldn't take me.
I was like, "What am I here for?"
- [Gary] At this prep school.
- Yeah, "I'm here, I wanna play lacrosse."
- I'm a fifth year senior.
- "I don't own a car, I can't
go out, I can't leave campus."
- [Gary] Where were you?
- Deerfield Academy in Massachusetts.
- So you're in Mass.
- [Rob] Yeah, Deerfield, Mass.
- So you're in Deerfield, Mass.
All you're friends are literally, like,
six, eight weeks into their college lives.
You're in this high school.
- I'm in a single dorm room with the
center of the football team.
They added a bed for me to get in there.
It was a high school, yeah.
Just like, "What am I doing?"
- And when did Cornell call?
- November, I went up for homecoming
and hit it off with the coaching staff.
The coach called me back,
he's like, "Do you wanna come?"
I was like, "Well, I have no other options
"so yeah, let's do it."
And I played the National Championship
my freshmen year at Cornell.
- That's fucking crazy.
So literally in October you were a
fifth year senior in wherever fucking Mass
and literally that spring/summer,
you're in the NCAA tournament,
playing for the National Championship.
- [Rob] Yeah, crazy.
- That was an intense eight months.
- Oh, yeah.
- So what did you see around you
in this highly competitive
northeast environment?
You just saw a lot of parents fucking up?
Or did you even realize it was happening?
You were a kid.
Did you see dads yelling,
just like lack of self-awareness?
Like a kid that you knew sucked shit
in junior high that had no prayer
because he didn't have the
size or the speed or the skill,
but his dad, when he came over,
literally thinks his
son's gonna be at Hopkins?
- I think you see it today more than ever.
- [Gary] Why?
From your perspective.
- Yeah, I mean, everything
that you touched on,
I think it's just like
that notion that parents,
that they want their kids to think that--
They wanna be positive,
think that they're gonna
be this great thing.
I would have like five
goals in youth league
and I would come off the field,
my dad would be like, "You
missed this one on the crease,
"and you missed this guy
who was wide open there."
- Do you feel like that
can go far the other way?
- I feel like that's why I'm here today,
is because my dad was so critical of me.
- Do you think if your
dad was sitting here,
that if I asked him, "Hey, bro,
"do you think that you, dad,
would've had the self-awareness
"that your son wasn't
dealing with that well,
"that you would've been able to
"take the foot off the pedal,"
or do you think your dad
had one move the other way.
Because I think most
parents have one move,
one way or the other,
and I'm most fascinated by the parent
that has the ability to go to the middle
when they react to the reality
versus their own ambition?
- I think he would've.
I think he saw how I reacted to it
and I was competitive,
it was positive for me,
and then eventually when
I got to high school--
- You had friends that had dads or moms
doing the same thing
that crumbled under that
and wanted to punch
their parent in the face.
- Absolutely, absolutely.
- Yeah, my mom was a
professional tennis player.
She lost in the semifinals of Wimbledon,
like did the thing.
- Your mom lost--
- To Billy Jean King,
semifinals of Wimbledon in '68, I think.
- I have to look that
up as you're talking.
- Yeah, Cathleen Harder.
- [Gary] That's insane.
- She was the real deal and
so when I was playing ball,
I was a basketball player--
- You're a hundredth of
the athlete your mom is.
- Yeah, totally.
Yeah, she could beat me in
tennis until I was like 32.
And that was only because mobility.
Strokes, she's still better,
and she would just laugh at me,
but I think her experience
in knowing that,
I mean, losing is a part of
life and she understood that,
and it was just how you deal with it
and what you take from it,
but her love never
wavered when I won or lost
and I can't say the same for my dad.
My dad was never a great athlete
and he was more ego-invested
in my performance,
and I think with him it was a lot tougher
because he didn't really understand
what it was like to play at a high level
and his attitude towards me changed.
If I had a bad game or
if I missed some shots,
you know, then it was
like, "Where'd dad go?"
Like, "Dad doesn't give a shit
about me anymore," you know?
Or he would like jump on me for stuff
and I was like, "I'm already
better than you, I'm 12.
"What are you doing, dad?"
So it was a balance of
having both types of parents,
but I think ultimately the job of a parent
is to prepare you for life,
and losing is a part of life,
it's just what you do with that loss.
Do you use it to make you better
or do you use it to make you feel like
you aren't worthy of love anymore?
And that's with them.
- I'm super fascinated by
the absolute value of losing.
I'm just super into it,
and I'm just shocked by
the lack of self-awareness
of parents to realize it's
doing such a huge disservice.
I just see so many of my
friends and contemporaries,
like, it's just so obvious that the fear
of losing just cripples
them because they never--
Like, it's super important
to taste that shit early on.
Interesting.
- And taste the result of that, you know?
The best thing that you can do,
as any parent or any mentor or anybody,
is take the worst possible thing,
the thing that's the curse,
the things that's the loss,
and say, "Now, how do you
become grateful for this?
"How is this going to make you better?"
And you teach that, that's
the fucking recipe for life.
Whatever failure, whatever loss,
whatever curse, whatever hardship,
use that thing to make
you that much stronger,
teach that shit.
- Do you feel that you're
over-reliant on Instagram?
So this is something I wanna
spend a lot of time on,
it's the first time I'm bringing it out,
it's super important for me.
I've got better sense for you,
and I think you're more diversified.
You know, as people are clearly trying
to figure out their value in the--
Thank God for influencer market,
listen to your two intros, right?
You know, it's really fun to critique
the parents of the world right now
and we just had a lot of
fun razzing not ourselves,
do you believe, very simple yes, no,
do you believe that you're
too vulnerable to Instagram?
- Yes and no.
I mean, that's the thing.
I've done basically my same
job for 20 years or so,
and like he mentioned, you know,
we're both in unique sports that don't--
- [Gary] They're not mainstream.
- They're not mainstream
and I'm also coming off of,
you know, a career of competing as well.
So yeah, I mean--
- So you retired a year ago?
- I still do events but not full-time.
- And did that feel weird?
Was that like a detox or was that gradual?
Did you feel like that was happening
over the last three or four years?
- I felt like it was gradual,
and like I mentioned I like to win,
so where I felt like I
couldn't dedicate my time and--
- At the highest levels?
- Yeah, like I don't
wanna show up to events
and not do good or not
feel like I gave it my all,
so that's kind of where I was at.
- [Gary] You lost the
energy for it, makes sense.
- But, you know, I still think about it.
I still have, you know, surf
meets in the Olympics for 2020,
that's something that's--
- Is it the first time?
- First time, yeah.
- [Gary] Are you like, "Fuck."
- No, I literally tell
a story where I cried
when I heard I got in.
- I couldn't imagine.
- I was like, "Wow."
- [Gary] The timing's super weird.
- Yeah, it is weird.
- It was '16 or if it was '24,
it would've been better for you?
- Yeah, I mean, and also I
think what's interesting to me,
I even, ten, twenty years
ago when I was competing,
we barely had a girl's tour or anything
and now it's, like, an Olympic sport
and I'm, you know, very grateful
and I feel like I
contributed to a lot of--
Me and another few top surfers
to get surfing out there.
- Meanwhile, you can't help
but running through your head,
like, "Fuck, I could've
won an Olympic gold medal."
- You never know, it's on my mind.
- But you would have to legitimately--
- [Anastasia] Quit everything.
- If you're planning on doing it,
you probably have to
leave right this second.
- Exactly, I'll see you guys in two years.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Which it runs through my mind.
I'm like, "Hmm," you know?
- On a very serious note,
if you literally walked
out of this room right now
and went to Hawaii and started
getting your shit together,
you know, it's tough.
People are so confused by
the difference between,
like, you fooling around
with your friends and what--
I actually think that is one of the most
fascinating things to me in my life,
that regular people can't
comprehend the delta
between themselves and
the tippy top of a sport.
Like, my friends always say dumb shit,
if we play five-on-five pickup ball
and when you get the right five together
and you, like, really feel it,
and then somebody says something stupid
because you won, like,
seven games in a row,
like, "You, if we played the Warriors--"
Like, "When are you gonna score, dick?"
Forget about winning,
we're not even gonna score
if they really tried.
Score in a basketball game.
I always tell my friends, I'm like,
"Bro, look at all the NCAA athletes,
"look at the ones that are like
"the seventh best player
in college at the time
"that don't even make
it to the next level."
The delta is so extreme.
Do you think that if you walked outta here
right now and started going hardcore,
that you could make a real run in 2020?
- It would be a struggle.
It would be a struggle.
And that's where it's like, "Ugh."
- If you thought you could medal,
you'd probably walk out of here right now.
Because it's cool, right?
- Yeah, well yeah.
- I apologize for cutting you off.
I notice Lewis Howes has a quote here,
Lewis went to the Olympics
on a handball thing,
I still think it's the funniest shit.
Like, literally, when he did that,
there was one flight where I was like,
"What's something super random
that's in the Olympics?"
Like, something dumb as shit
that nobody knows about.
I was, like, looking for the
hack to get into the Olympics
because I think it's just
funny and it's amazing.
Got it, so that's kinda how
it runs through your mind.
- Yeah, and to further
answer your question,
speaking back to Instagram and, you know,
working with brands and stuff--
- [Gary] Look, what's your
second biggest platform?
- Facebook's actually my number one,
but, I mean, Facebook,
Instagram, I do them all,
Twitter, Snapshot,
but it's like anything.
Like, I think every day,
"Is it gonna change?"
I just saw Myspace Tom
literally yesterday in LA.
I know him, he's a nice
guy, and I was like,
"Myspace Tom, what's up?"
- Do you think he appreciated you saying
Myspace Tom or did you just say Tom?
- I say both.
I literally might go, "Yo,
you're, like, Myspace Tom,"
and I'm like, "This is great."
But I was on Myspace back in the day,
I was a really geeky kid.
- You also were building a brand at five,
so that makes sense.
Do you feel like you're
over-reliant on Instagram?
- Yes.
- Do you even have a number two?
- Probably Twitter.
- But that's like a distant two, right?
- It's probably a fourth, yeah,
of my following on Instagram.
- And so how do you think about that?
Do you think about podcasts,
do you think about YouTube?
- Yeah, I think, like I
said, right now I'm more
focused on that more than ever.
I think I'm at a point in my
life where I'm comfortable
and wanna start getting
into different things.
- Comfortable because you
scratched the itch of lacrosse
or comfortable because
you're starting to get
some deals and, like, can see it?
Number two?
- I have some deals and I'm comfortable
where I'm at in the sport.
You know, I'm always
trying to be the best,
but I'm, you know,
confident in my position
right now and where I am,
and I wanna start really
taking that next step.
So I'm looking at
podcasts, YouTube channel,
seeing what I can do best,
what I can do with the most consistency
because I think that's
what I admire the most
about people who are in this
space and who do it great,
is how consistent they are.
And, you know, you're putting
out podcasts every day
and that takes effort, that takes work,
so what's my next go-to platform
that I can be consistent in?
I wanna be a consistent performer
like I can be in lacrosse,
I wanna do that with what I choose next,
and for now, right now,
Instagram's the one
that I can be most consistent with.
- Aubrey, how about for you?
And how do you think about you as a human
versus Onnit the brand?
- That's a funny thing to kinda
reconcile at a certain point
because it was birthed out of me,
it was just me.
Me and Onnit were smashed together as one
and now 180 people in there,
and it has a life of
its own and it's my job
to just kind of shepherd it
and steer it in the right ways
that uphold certain principles of mine,
but it's its own thing for sure
and it can get kinda trippy
to look at this thing
that was like a piece of my flesh,
that now has developed into
something that's no longer me.
- What's the biggest
challenge of something
that is a piece of your flesh.
that is now a company of 180 people.
For you today.
How many years ago did it start?
- 2011 was really when it got going.
- So, like, you know, what's
the biggest challenge for you?
At this point because I think
you're in an interesting spot,
I have a lot of empathy for it.
A lot of times we talk about, you know,
so much of my content
is geared towards people
that haven't started yet or you're in.
You, I, we're past those
places in our lives.
I feel like you're in a place where your
personal brand is gaining moment, right?
You have been focused on Onnit.
You know, listen, I always
try to remind people,
like, I built Wine Library
for the first decade.
No, I got lucky, let's call it what it is.
There was no putting out
content, you know, back then,
but there was blogs and
I can't write for shit
so that helped me,
but Myspace, I watched very carefully,
Friendster and Myspace, I was fascinated.
I didn't start content on there.
You know, I think it's
an interesting transition
when you actually run a company
and then some of the attention goes to you
and you start realizing
there's a double benefit.
I mean, this book is
gonna be great for you,
it's gonna be great for the business.
- [Aubrey] Yeah.
- Do you worry about getting caught on
the drug of being the person,
and that then makes you take
an eye off the business?
- It's a balance, you know?
Because to write this book I
can't be focused on other stuff
so you have to trust the
people that you put in place
and you have to allow some flexibility
for the company to take on
some of their personality.
Like my COO, my CTO,
they are shaping Onnit
in a certain way and, again--
- And talk to me about 2007 Onnit.
- 2011, yeah.
- I'm sorry, I apologize.
Let's talk about 2014 Onnit.
Onnit in 2014, what percentage of
your fingerprints is on that business?
- I mean, the whole thing.
- 100?
100, 99, like?
- In 2014, I mean, in every aspect,
every single aspect other than the coding.
- [Gary] Give me a net.
But you hired that coder?
- Well, if we're talking
about people I hire,
we're talking, like, 92% of this company.
- Of the 50 biggest decisions
that happened that year,
how many did you make?
- 49.
- Right, and now in 2018?
- I mean, now we're talking closer to 35%.
- And of the 50 biggest decisions?
- I'm still making the majority of those,
maybe 40, 42.
- [Gary] Understood.
And what does that feel like?
Do you feel back to, doing a recall,
your ability to go to
that psychedelic place?
It is a little "ha-ha",
I'm enjoying the recall of it,
but I do think it's an
interesting insight.
Do you believe that your
escapism in that form
and trying to learn to
control the uncontrollable
and however one would define that sector,
I wanna use the right
adjectives and words,
do you think that has helped you let go?
- 1000%, yeah, because
you learn to have trust.
And also, read deeply into the
subconscious patterns that people have
because you see them in yourself
and you can see them in other people
because you've gotta really trust
the people that you're
hanging over the reins to,
especially for the important decisions.
And so I feel like I
can see them, read them,
I can share myself with them better
so that they understand me better,
so that there's not this discrepancy
of, "Oh, what would Aubrey say,"
or, "What would Aubrey do?"
They can kind of keep my spirit alive,
even when I'm not there,
and make decisions that would be akin
to the decisions that I would make.
So that's helped and also, yeah,
letting go and trusting that this will
become what it's supposed to become.
- Let's end on a speed round.
Gonna ask some questions,
everybody answers.
What's the most interesting thing
happening on Instagram right now?
- I touched on it earlier,
I think the real-time stories.
I think real-time stories and the geotags.
- Love it.
Could be a single account,
could be a single person,
could be something
happening in your community.
- Yeah.
Yeah, I don't know.
- What's the first thing you do
when you go to Instagram in the morning.
Do you go to your DMs?
Do you go look at how
your last post performed?
Do you go into explore?
Do you go through your feed?
What's the first thing you do?
- I just go through my feed, really.
- [Gary] And do you like shit?
- Yeah, I like stuff, yeah.
I think that, actually,
that's a good point right there.
I think I find fascinating the likes.
I found, I think, people are just
scrolling more and liking less,
and it's just kinda become a habit
where you just scroll.
- [Gary] Consuming instead of engaging.
- One of the coolest
things I've watched happen
is one of the trainers in our gym,
he goes by Primal Swoldier,
and I've watched him come up from nothing,
now to like 150 thousand followers,
and he's just swinging kettle bells
and then he launched his
own training program.
And with just Instagram alone,
in the span of like 18 months,
he's got a 100 thousand dollar business
with recurring and subscriptions
and things going on,
and just from being
relentless and consistent,
two different kettlebell flows,
he's sweaty, he's got his shirt off,
he's got short shorts,
he's got a black hat,
and he does it every single day.
And now I go out to eat
in Miami and I'll have,
like, an Onnit supplement on the table
and they'll be like, "Oh, shit,
"you work with Primal Swoldier."
I'm like, "Yeah, I do actually."
"Well, tell him I said what's up."
And it's just cool to see
someone use the platform.
- I get it.
Fucking D-Rock, you know?
Fucking ridiculous.
Okay, favorite food right now.
- I'm really into matcha drink or acai.
That's, like, been my go-to, yeah.
- I'm gonna go with beverage,
I've really gotten into molecular hydrogen
and consuming that consistently
throughout the day.
- [Gary] Interesting.
- Yeah, it's weird.
It's different, yeah.
- I've been playing around
with exogenous ketones,
and that's--
- Here's my favorite part
of this last question.
I don't even know what the
fuck the last two were.
I've never heard of ether.
- That's what I'm excited about,
is somebody who said, "It's the ultimate
"energy source to sugar for the system."
You can obviously have
a full ketogenic diet,
which I'm a fan of but this will kind of
help bridge the gap and
help you cheat a little bit,
and so really playing around with those.
Onnit doesn't have any of those right now,
but I'm playing around
with them personally.
- It's funny, though.
I actually have a weird one too
and I don't even know
the proper name for it,
but there's popcorn that has--
I don't remember the first word,
but it's yeast as the
topping instead of butter.
I don't know if it's--
- Like nutritional yeast?
- You know about this?
Nutritional yeast, I think is right.
Have you had that?
- [Aubrey] It tastes kinda like cheese.
- Dude, it's fucking amazing.
- [Aubrey] It's really good.
- It, like, freaks me
out how delicious it is.
Like, I like it way better than butter
and, like, butter's the
best on popcorn for me,
like historically.
What are you binging
or consuming on Netflix
or any other OTT or HBO or what have you?
Nothing is a fair answer.
- Yeah, nothing.
Yeah.
- [Gary] That's nothing.
- I'm excited for Westworld to come back.
- [Gary] Yes, but right now it's nothing.
- Nothing.
- The last thing was Peaky Blinders,
I went through that.
- [Gary] Oh, yeah, was that great?
People loved it.
- I loved it, yeah, it was great.
- Yeah, if I could wait in line
and it would make Westworld happen faster,
if I could go iPhone style and
get it before everybody else,
I fucking would.
I love that show, love that show.
- Last parting shot.
This is where you can promote a book
or ask a question or
anything you'd like to say,
let's wrap it up.
- Dude, this is awesome.
(laughing)
You know, here's a question for you, Gary.
- Actually, that would be great,
if you would ask me a
question since I gotta
bounce right after this and can't hang.
- What would be better for your
wall of things or things for the office?
A surfboard or a bikini?
- A surfboard.
I think I'm going to put
up something pretty legit.
I'm honestly thinking about
resetting the whole thing.
- [Anastasia] Okay, perfect.
Then I can be in the center.
- I'm thinking about super resetting
and, like, really going
there with shit I care about.
So, like, for example,
I'm gonna go on eBay
in the next couple days,
I need to buy, like, 80 wrestling figures.
Not just a couple,
like I'm gonna really make
it even more personal.
Right now, people are like
sneaking in and putting shit.
It's just not enough me
and so I need to reset it,
but a surfboard would be great.
I'd do some sort of Anchor thing.
- I'm gonna do two things.
I wanna ask you a question,
but first thing I wanna say is
right now I started an Instagram account,
I'm doing Fit 30 with Brian Mazza
and it's our daily
workouts under 30 minutes.
So we put a lot of time into that.
Well, thank you, this is cool.
I actually started
taking Onnit supplements
a few weeks ago,
been friends with you for a while.
- You really won today.
- I listen to his podcast, Tim Farris,
and started taking his supplements
and following him for a few weeks,
so this is awesome.
Talking about that second social,
what should I use,
where do you think I should go?
- I think it's reverse
engineering what you're about.
So to me, it's like if you can write,
I really, really believe writing is
grossly underestimated right now.
Like, one think I know for a fact
is most people on Instagram right now
are grossly mailing in the copy
and focusing way too much on the picture.
Obviously the picture's massive
and even if it's 80%,
which I would be
comfortable in saying it is,
the visual is 80%,
that would leave 20% around the copy
and its impact on the success
of, "What are we doing here?"
We're trying to put out pieces of content
that give us distribution and awareness,
that becomes a gateway drug to another
thing that we want to happen,
whether that's to sell
supplements or sneakers or books,
or to, like, "I wanna
make more people Jet fans
"and make them more
aware of other things."
Whatever it is,
I could care less of like
what you want that to be.
To me, it's if you can
me great at the craft
of getting people to pay attention,
attention is the currency,
and everybody is mailing in copy.
So if you could write, I think blogging
and copy on your posts is super huge.
I mean, I couldn't push people
more to starting a podcast
if they're willing to go there, right?
Like, I own 0.00% of
Anchor and everybody thinks
I own all of it because I always push it,
only because I know it's a very easy way
for people to start a podcast, right?
So, to me, written and audio
because video and picture
has become easy and second
nature to everybody.
That means the opportunity is in video--
Excuse me, in written word and audio.
- [Rob] Thank you.
- You got it, Aub?
- Yeah, I mean, right now I'm in the
final stages of this book launch.
- What are you doing on Tuesday
when the book comes out?
- I'm gonna be signing some books,
but doing a lot of Facebook Lives,
doing a lot of digital.
I've got different digital
platforms that are hitting me up
and just trying to--
- Email blasts from homies.
- Through the Onnit list, through my list,
through everybody possible.
100% pod committed.
There's no more, we pushed all in,
and it's great, man.
There's nothing that I've ever seen
that's combined the entire spectrum
of human optimization into a single place,
so you don't need to go hunting
for conflicting experts.
We got 300 clinical academic references.
And it's not about buying
a bunch of Onnit stuff,
we're talking about the free doctors,
like sex and sleep and exercise
and light and hydration.
- How much do you sleep?
- I sleep about seven hours,
and then I take 30-minute naps a lot.
- What range?
- About one to eight.
- Is your sweet spot?
- Is about my sweet spot.
- What's your sleep?
- Six to eight.
- Cool, six to eight hours.
What's the norm?
- I wake up at seven so it's all depending
on when I fall asleep.
11, 12 to 7.
- [Gary] Got it, and for you?
- 10, 11 until 6, 7.
- I'm really, really midnight
to 6 or 11 to 6, you know?
I'm the same.
The reason I wanted to jump
on this before we ended
is I'm just super sad that people think
hustle means sleep four hours.
To me, the biggest problem is what are you
doing when you're awake?
- How much energy do you have?
- Yeah, exactly.
And that's exactly right.
It's just the black-and-white
of not a lot of hours
and making that cool is
such a strategic mistake.
- And a 30-minute nap
outperformed more overnight sleep
and more coffee in clinical research.
So don't be afraid to nap,
even if you're fucking killing it.
- On that, you need to
know your body, right?
Like I can't nap.
Like, I just can't.
I think any of these
advices about anything
comes down to self-awareness
and understanding yourself.
Like, trying different
things to figure out
that thing for you is just the game.
- You might wanna try
a caffeine nap, then.
Where you have a little bit of caffeine
and then try and nap so
you don't go too deep.
Because the problem with
napping and being tired
is you get into the deep phases of sleep,
and if you're in the deep phases of sleep
and pull yourself out rather than being
in REM or some lighter phase--
- There's nothing worse
than fucking waking up
when you're asleep.
You're, like, dead.
- You don't want that.
You wanna wake up from the light sleep
or not even go down that deep in a nap.
Just touch the surface of
that theta brainwave state.
- Guys, thanks for being on.
- Thank you.
- Have a great day, see ya!
(energetic rhythmic music)